or nextar Media Group
tonight on politics now protecting our
election we speak with the head of Clark
County Elections as the midterms close
in Plus
you can absolutely be strong on border
security and absolutely do right by our
dreamers and their family members we
speak with Senator Catherine Cortez
masto about immigration the economy and
abortion
it was not we who were shutting down or
making determinations about
what was essential that was a
gubernatorial determination
Clark County Commissioner Jim Gibson
also up for reelection he talks to us
about coronavirus response and water in
Lake Mead
[Music]
this is politics now
thank you very much for joining us I'm
John Langer election day is three weeks
away early voting started today this
week eight news now investigator Vanessa
Murphy toured the Clark County election
headquarters and she spoke with the
Registrar of Voters Joe Gloria about
election security
obviously there's a lot of controversy
surrounding the male ballots what can
you say to ensure that people will not
just take a bunch of ballots sign them
hand them in
well there's a process involved with
taking that and making sure that they're
valid ballots to be submitted we use the
signature as a check for identity on all
of those ballots it runs through our
mail ballot processing machine the
software verifies some of those
signatures and then it goes to a manual
signature verification process and if it
fails there it then goes to the Cure
which means that voters need will be
contacted they if we have an email or
phone number we contact them through
that and also through the mail and they
can very easily call or use our app our
text secure app in order to cure that
ballot and have it counted so there's a
lot of verification that goes into
making sure so you can't just grab a
ballot sign it and send it in and assume
it's going to be counted it won't the
signature won't match based on your
experience you've been doing this for a
while can you sort of talk about the
controversy about election integrity and
sort of the claims of election fraud and
there really is not much evidence of
that
absolutely unfortunately those have been
claims that have been disproven there
were several court cases that went in in
2020 and none of them were successful
there are a lot of details that go into
voter registration you don't necessarily
have to live here you could be in the
military you could be a student who's
studying abroad
we allow all of those people we follow
state law and we make sure that those
people are eligible to vote and
eligibility to be registered we also go
through an extensive process to work to
keep our voter registration roles clean
so as far as upholding the Integrity of
what we do we follow the law federal and
state and we've done our best effort and
I'm convinced that we're upholding the
Integrity here in Clark County
Vanessa also spoke with Gloria about
signature verification and how that
system is tested you can see that part
of the discussion at 8newsnow.com
Nevada's Senate race well it's the most
watched in the country incumbent
Democrat Catherine Cortez masto she's
trying to fend off a challenge from
Republican Adam laxalt this week Brian
Loftus sat down with Senator Cortez
masto to ask about the issues she says
are at the top of Voters Minds
we appreciate your time now 40 percent
of Nevada and say their standard of
living is worse than four years ago rent
is up gas is up food what do you say to
these voters these nevadans well I I
know a high class are squeezing Nevada
families because I hear from them and my
own families I live in this community
and I'm frustrated like them that's why
it was important that we passed the
inflation reduction act we start
lowering health care costs allowing
prescription drug negotiation capping
the cost of insulin at 35 a month
helping our seniors you know is proud to
stand with AARP and really fight to help
lower costs for seniors in the inflation
reduction act we also for families and
help them lower their energy costs in
their homes there's a lot of work being
done there but there's more that needs
to be done there's no doubt about it you
know
um my mother is in this community and
like everyone else when we go grocery
shopping I hear it you know when she's
making her meatballs I hear it she lets
you know about it we talk and and that's
why it's important for us to to work
together to lower costs and I will say
um this is a perfect example at the gas
pump why we need to be energy
independent and we have to hold big oil
companies accountable why aren't they
working with us to put more Supply in
there they're sitting on 9000 permits
that they could be drilling on instead
they're making profits so there is an
opportunity for us to work together and
that's why I called them out in energy
and natural resources committee that's
why for me introducing legislation to
stop price gouging because it's
squeezing Nevada families I see it and
feel it in in my own family and I hear
it from the band so there there's more
work we all need to do together with the
American Rescue plan and the inflation
reduction Act was it too much Senator
did the spending go too far in terms of
the claim that it triggered inflation
well I will tell you the inflation
reduction Act actually pays for itself
that's that actually pays for itself and
requiring billionaires and large
corporations to to pay more and it
reduces the deficit by 300
000 billion dollars so uh it really is
uh something that we needed in this
community to start lowering costs and
that's why listen that's why Chief
economists under previous
administrations both Republicans and
Democrats supported it we needed to do
that to Circle back to something you
said regarding energy Independence do we
need our pipelines on domestic pipelines
in the United States and Canada do we
need those to rely on those in terms of
helping get the cost of gas back down
well I will tell you in Nevada most
people don't realize our pipelines come
from California and what's happening
right now the refineries in California
they're not all working the oil
companies have shut down a couple of
those refineries and that's why I say it
really is time for us to be energy and
independent if this is a perfect example
from geopolitical challenges to OPEC to
what we see with big oil it is now time
for family police to stop being squeezed
and be energy independent what I mean by
that is listen we are in a state that's
primed for solar and geothermal and to
lean in the clean energy economy we have
the complete ecosystem for a batteries
for electric vehicles and electric buses
we have an opportunity now to really
help families in lower costs and lean
into that Independence Nevada is primed
for this and this is this is the
bipartisan infrastructure package that I
fought for to bring money into the state
to to get us going in that future it's
going to create great paying jobs it
will be good for our economy and it
really will be good for our communities
Around clean energy around smart
Community smart Transportation that's
happening here in the state of Nevada
and it's an exciting time to really take
those Investments put those here for our
future which will benefit not just our
families now but our children long term
would you support any restrictions on
abortion after 24 weeks I support
Nevada's law which has codified Rove
versus white in his progeny I think it
is important for people to understand
that that in Nevada in 1990 is when we
actually had a voter referendum and the
people of Nevada said no this is where
we want to be so I support this law in
the state of Nevada are you surprised
when you look at the recent New York
Times Siena Paul that abortion is so low
in terms of economy inflation the issues
that are important to voters come three
weeks abortion barely breaking into the
top ten does that surprise you I will
tell you what I hear from the veterans
because that's my focus is it's not just
kitchen table issues which rightfully
should be but it's also the repeal of
Roe versus Wade this is an issue as I
get around the state and talk to voters
they are concerned about for the reasons
that we just said because there is the
voter referendum voters have decided
that they support a woman's right to
choose but it crosses party lines I've
heard from Democrats Republicans
Independence I've heard from women and
men what is your view on a path to
citizenship around route to citizenship
for dreamers I think they should be on
the pathway to citizenship dreamers I
think it is so important our essential
workers that were on the front line of
the pandemic are some of our dreamers
and TPS recipients it is they're in our
community this is the only really place
where they have lived or known and they
are hard-working and are Central and
they want to pay taxes they want to be a
part of our economy and they want to be
an essential part of of who we are not
just in this community in this country
so I do think it is important to put
them on a pathway but I also know this
I'm also for strong border security you
can do both you can absolutely be strong
on border security and absolutely do
right by our dreamers and their family
now specifically how would we and should
be stronger on border security what
needs to be done it's clearly a problem
yeah I can tell you as attorney general
this was an issue that was so important
for me that's why I created
relationships with the AGS in Mexican
states
because we came together for the first
time and I actually was the first
attorney general to enter in agreements
with those AGS of the Mexican Mexican
states to address drug trafficking that
we saw a lot crossing the border in the
South human trafficking weapons
trafficking and money laundering those
issues are still important for us to
address today along the border and
that's why when I first got to the
Senate the one of the first things I did
was bring the head of border patrol to
my office I got him on the phone
actually and said what is it we need
just a quick question on crime we've
seen what the Criminal Justice Reform
bills in 2019 some of the fund the
police movement crime in certain cities
across our country skyrocketing what do
we need to do in our big cities in
Nevada specifically Las Vegas to make
sure we're not going down the path that
we've seen in maybe New York or L.A or
Portland yeah I'm not far defining the
police nor have I ever said that or have
been and just the opposite I've worked
in law enforcement I'm married to law
enforcement retired law enforcement what
we need to do is ensure we're supporting
our law enforcement communities that's
why I've worked really in a bipartisan
way with Chuck Grassley Senator to
increase the Jag grant funding that
comes into our communities to to support
our law enforcement that's why based on
all of the conversations that I've had
with law enforcement we actually
introduce legislation based on what I
heard here in this state to address the
suicide rate to make sure we are
providing the resources they need around
their mental health around training and
mount so many other things that's why
I'm proud to have the support and the
endorsement of law enforcement in this
state
you can see Brian loftus's full
interview with the senator on
8newsnow.com now we should point out
we've also interviewed Adam laxalt the
Republican Challenger on this program
and we hope to have an interview with
him here soon as well Senator Cortez
masto is still raising more money than
Adam black salt with three weeks left
her campaign has a little more than 5
million dollars in cash on hand Mr
laxalt has a little more than four
million dollars Senator Cortez masso has
spent more than 20 million dollars
laxalt has spent about 20 percent of
that 4.3 million dollars
from coronavirus to water issues coming
up next on politics now County
Commissioner Jim Gibson speaks with us
about his re-election campaign and more
changes suggested for school boards
around Nevada the latest proposal from
the lieutenant governor
message
welcome back to politics now
tonight we continue our profile of the
race for Clark County Commission Now
last week we spoke with Republican Billy
Mitchell this week I sat down with the
man he is challenging for the Clark
County Commission incumbent Democrat and
chair Jim Gibson I started off asking
him about the public administrator's
office
was there anything else that you could
have done for those people uh in that
office well I think we did what we could
do for the people there
we took some administrative
responsibility just because there are
people we don't run the office we're not
the legal officer that can do the things
that need to be done although Mike is
deputized so he can function there you
know if there were anything maybe the
public administrator shouldn't even be
in elected office could we have done
something well I know one of our members
tried to do that when she was in the
legislature but I know I think it takes
a legislative action to do that let's
switch gears let's talk about the the
election itself Europe for re-election
obviously
um and let's talk about what's happened
in the last couple of years with the
County Commission the biggest challenges
you've had to deal with through covid
and everything else how would you grade
your performance getting through the
depths of the pandemic
frankly I think we worked well together
there was always going to be conflict
both internally because we have
different views about things and with
others you know the business Community
was frantic to get back open early on no
one was coming to Las Vegas so because
we're dependent upon tourism and
travelers and Airlines were shut down
and there were empty buildings it it was
something that was it didn't require a
lot of action on the part of anyone but
it was not we who were shutting down or
making determinations about
what was essential that was a
gubernatorial determination what we did
was we worked within the confines of his
emergency powers to enable a restart at
some point and we were working very hard
trying to make the case where it was
appropriate that it was time to reopen
some things and to allow other things to
begin to get ready to be open I also
want to just touch on something else
that your opponent has brought up and
you know you've had a long political
career you were the mayor in Henderson
you've you've been in politics for a
long time here there have been
accusations made with regards to ethics
campaign financing debt from when you
are the mayor of Henderson sort of
lingering Financial fiscal issues that
are that are sort of being brought up to
be critical of your performance how do
you tell voters that you're the best
Steward of their money that when you're
in office you're the best person to
represent them and get the county moving
forward well first of all in the city of
Henderson we operated on a really tight
budget and always always were operating
within the parameters that were assigned
so there was no debt you know when there
was a loose comment that wasn't intended
to convey the message that was conveyed
when the mayor who succeeded me said I
inherited a 90 million dollar deficit
well there are no deficit what he
inherited was a circumstance a session
that was rolling in as I was leaving
office and so we had already done a
voluntary retirement program and we'd
saved considerable money on payroll we
were cutting back in areas that were
really important keeping we had even
debate about do we leave rec centers
open or do we close no we need those
more than anything they're paid for
people don't have to pay to go there but
we were having those debates as I left
office I want to talk about the future
we talked a little bit maybe too much
about the past here the future here one
of the major issues for Clark County is
water you and I have talked about this
before if you're re-elected next four
years what can Clark County do you're
talking about getting a seat at the
table what can Clark County do to try
and address what's happening at Lake
Mead Beyond issues with Turf and pools
and so forth well keep in mind that four
percent of the water that comes out of
Lake Mead comes to Nevada four percent
so what what we've been doing is
preparing ourselves for whatever the
next iterate duration of challenges on
the river may be my opponent thinks that
the reason the lake is going down is
that California is taking too much water
out it wouldn't matter if California
were doing our program
there would still not be enough water in
the lake because there's a drought
we have a full interview with Jim Gibson
and the interview we did with his
opponent Billy Mitchell at 8newsnow.com
next on politics now battling for
control of the Senate CBS news's Lilia
Luciano looks inside to that is closely
watched Senate rates
live at 6 on 8 news now you're watching
politics now
as we've discussed Nevada is one of the
key state States in this election cycle
some of the biggest races could decide
the balance of power in Washington a new
CBS new poll news poll shows Democratic
senator Catherine Cortez masto is still
locked in a very close re-election race
with Republican Adam laxalt Lele Luciano
followed both of them on the campaign
Trail
as you know this is an incredibly tight
race and one where the voters here in
Nevada your viewers
where the stakes are it might determine
who controls the Senate 8 out of 10
voters in our Battleground tracker
realized said that they understand that
they are voting in this election not
just for their Senator but who takes
control of the senate in Washington
foreign
states in the Nevada midterm races are
high and odds are Latinos will decide
making up 20 percent of the state's
electorate Governor House and Senate
candidates are reaching out to secure
votes among the fastest growing minority
the more powerful and effective in a
list Culinary Union knocking on more
than a million doors ahead of this
election why are you doing this I'm
doing this because I think the one of
the issues that I'm most concerned about
is the housing right now I wish um it
wasn't so expensive plan to take away
the freedom this year the union endorsed
incumbent Democratic senator Catherine
Cortes masto who made history as the
first Latina ever in the Senate but the
CBS News Battleground tracker shows her
statistically tied with her opponent
former Nevada attorney general Adam
laxalt so even after hours Cortez masto
is making the rounds my focus is on
nevadans that's always been my priority
whether it's a small business owner like
you have here or it's families that are
one every opportunity to succeed for
themselves and their kids that's what
it's about for me that's the work that I
get to do in the Senate every day for a
state hit hard by covet closures with
inflation and gas prices among the
highest in the country voting in this
election is about nothing more than
making ends meet says laxalt's advisor
Jesus Marquez Latinos in the past used
to think that okay we need to vote for a
Latina or a Latino but now it doesn't
matter if whether it's Latino or not as
long as it takes care of the problems I
can only tell you yeah that what I hear
from Nevada and it it really is the same
story for all of us which is that
American Dream you know it is the
opportunity to succeed but her opponent
has a fierce finger pointed at Democrats
as to why that dream is Out Of Reach
yeah tell them look outside and
everything their experience is a direct
result of Joe Biden and Senator
Catherine Cortez masto all the pain
they're feeling today at the pump at the
grocery store in their family budgets is
a direct result of policy they're
killing the American dream there's work
that I've been able to do with in
conjunction with them to start figuring
how we lower those costs because we know
it's squeezing families I think the
inflation reduction Act was a great
first start but I do think absolutely
there's more that we can do together you
know it all comes down to who can
convince voters here in this state that
their Solutions are the ones that are
going to impact their finances
towards housing inflation is the cost of
living in here is well known gas prices
and the prices of you know everyday
products are higher than in other parts
of the country
[Music]
and that was Lily Luciano reporting more
politics
Toyota Let's Go Places you're watching
politics now
lieutenant governor Lisa Cano Burkhead
is suggesting a new bill to change the
makeup of our school boards her proposal
would add four appointed people to the
Clark County School Board for example a
president would be appointed by the
Clark County Commission the cities of
Las Vegas Henderson and North Las Vegas
would each get to a point one member as
well Cano Burkhead says it will be one
of her Bill draft requests in the 2023
session now she is a Democrat facing
reelection right now against Republican
Stavros Anthony
a few weeks ago we reported Nevada's
largest teachers union is not endorsing
a candidate in the gubernatorial race
that's the Clark County Education
Association which decided not to back
anyone however other educator unions
across the state are putting their
weight behind Governor sisalak that's
the Nevada State Education Association
School support staff they are endorsing
the incumbent ccean nsea are often at
loggerheads and this certainly shows a
difference of opinion all right that'll
do it for us this week here on politics
now all the latest political news of
course is at 8newsnow.com we'll see you
next week
foreign
[Music]